>> Tucker: MORE EVIDENCE THAT
THE SINISTER TECH MONOPOLY
GOOGLE IS NOT ON THE LEVEL AT
ALL WHAT HE CLAIMS TO BE.
GOOGLE EMPLOYEES DISCUSS
SUPPRESSING CONSERVATIVE NEWS
WEBSITES.
IN ONE POST FROM NOVEMBER 9TH OF
2016, A GOOGLE ENGINEER CALLED
SCOTT BIER CALLED
"THE DAILY CALLER" AND BREITBART
OPINION BLOGS AND SAID THAT
GOOGLE EMPLOYEES SHOULD REDUCE
THE VISIBILITY OF BOTH SITES AND
OTHER EMPLOYEES SAID IT WAS THE
COMPANY'S JOB TO PROVIDE MORE
CONTEXT TO REBUT MORE NEWS
CONTEXT THAT THEY DISLIKE.
ROBERT EPSTEIN IS A PSYCHOLOGIST
AT THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE FOR
BEHAVIORAL RESEARCH AND
TECHNOLOGY AND ONE OF THE PEOPLE
THAT'S PAID CLOSEST ATTENTION TO
THE POWER THAT GOOGLE HAS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
GOOGLE HAS SAID REPEATEDLY IT
DOES NOT MANIPULATE SEARCH
RESULTS BUT THIS IS NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO THE FIRST PIECE OF
EVIDENCE WE HAVE FROM WITHIN THE
COMPANY SHOWING GOOGLE EMPLOYEES
DISCUSSING WAYS TO MANIPULATE
SEARCH RESULTS.
CAN WE BE CONFIDENT THEY ARE NOT
DOING IT?
>> NOT AT ALL.
GOOGLE IS EXTREMELY GOOD AT
KEEPING ITS SECRETS FOR ALMOST
20 YEARS BUT IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS THAT HAS CHANGED AND
THERE HAVE BEEN QUITE A NUMBER
OF LEAKS AND WE HAVE SEEN A
NUMBER OF INTERNAL DISCUSSIONS
THERE LIKE THE ONE THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED.
THERE IS SIMPLY NO QUESTION THAT
THEY HAVE STRONG POLITICAL
LEANINGS AND I MYSELF AM NOT A
CONSERVATIVE, I ACTUALLY KIND OF
LEAN TOWARD GOOGLE'S POLITICAL
VIEWS, BUT IT'S FRIGHTENING TO
ME BECAUSE OF WHAT I STUDIED DAY
BY DAY, IT'S FRIGHTENING TO ME
THAT THIS COMPANY WITH VERY
STRONG POLITICAL LEANINGS HAS
THE POWER TO SHIFT MILLIONS OF
VOTES AND SHIFT OPINIONS ON A
MASSIVE SCALE WITHOUT PEOPLE
KNOWING THAT THEY ARE DOING IT
AND WITHOUT BEING ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PUBLIC.
>> Tucker: HOW CAN YOU HAVE A
DEMOCRACY UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE ONE
PRIVATELY HELD COMPANY HAS THE
POWER TO MANIPULATE PEOPLE'S
BEHAVIOR WITHOUT PEOPLE KNOWING
IT?
>> IF THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE.
THE SITUATION GETS EVEN WORSE
WHEN THESE HUGE TECH COMPANIES,
THE TWO LARGEST BEING GOOGLE AND
FACEBOOK, THEY BOTH HAVE THE
SAME POLITICAL LEANINGS.
AND THAT KIND OF SCENARIO, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE ABILITY TO
SHIFT IN THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
AND I CALCULATED UPWARDS OF
12 MILLION VOTES WITH NO ONE
HAVING ANY IDEA THAT THEY ARE
DOING THIS.
THIS IS NOT FAKE ADS WHICH YOU
CAN SEE, THIS IS AN VISIBLE
MANIPULATION.
I LITERALLY HAVE TO INVENT NEW
NAMES FOR THE TECHNIQUES THEY
ARE USING BECAUSE THEY HAVE
NEVER EXISTED BEFORE.
>> Tucker: SO GOOGLE ASSURES
US THAT THEY ARE NOT DOING THIS
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOOD PEOPLE,
MUCH BETTER PEOPLE THAN WE ARE
FOR EXAMPLE.
HOW CAN WE KNOW IF THEY ARE
TELLING THE TRUTH AND, SHOULD WE
BELIEVE THEM?
>> THEY ARE SURE THEY ARE GOOD
PEOPLE, THAT'S PART OF THE
PROBLEM.
THEY HAVE SOME UTOPIAN THINKING
WITHIN THE COMPANY, NOT JUST THE
EMPLOYEES BUT THEIR TOP
EXECUTIVES THINK LIKE UTOPIANS
SO, BELIEVE ME, THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY ARE DOING GOOD FOR
HUMANITY AND GOOD FOR THE
UNITED STATES BY IMPOSING THEIR
VALUES AND THEIR THINKING ON THE
REST OF US.
THE PROBLEM IS AS THEY SAY, THEY
CAN DO IT IN WAYS THAT HAVE
NEVER EXISTED BEFORE IN HUMAN
HISTORY.
>> Tucker: SO I KNOW WE SAID,
YOU AND I HAVE DIFFERENT
POLITICAL VIEWS, HOW CAN THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS SIT BACK
WITH EVIDENCE THAT THE CORE IDEA
OF DEMOCRACY IS BEING CHALLENGED
BY THIS COMPANY AND NOT DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT?
>> THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO DO
ANYTHING BECAUSE THESE COMPANIES
HELP THEM OBVIOUSLY.
THE REPUBLICANS DON'T LIKE
REGULATIONS SO WE HAVE A TOUGH
PROBLEM HERE IN THE U.S.
NOW THE EUROPEANS ON THE OTHER
HAND, THEY SEE THESE COMPANIES
AS AMERICAN, AND THEY HAVE BEEN
MUCH TOUGHER ON THEM.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO SEE SOME
PRETTY DRASTIC ACTIONS TAKEN
AGAINST THESE COMPANIES BY THE
E.U. IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS AND
THAT COULD CHANGE THEIR ABILITY
TO OPERATE WORLDWIDE.